all right yeah so I'm gonna give you a
brief tour off so I can learn today
before I'm gonna do that just a little
about myself so I did my PhD and in
computer science actually have a PhD in
computer science without taking any
classes it's a university in Bonn I did
a brief stint as machine learning at
Amazon and Berlin went to the NYU Center
for data science and I now lecturer at
the Columbia University in the data
Science Institute
so what ass I could learn so I could
learn is a Python library and it's a
Python library for machine learning and
I want to talk today about how this
might be different from what you're used
to instead of how machine learning is
viewed in scikit-learn and what are the
main paradigms so ii learned has a lot
of stuff in it it has a bunch of
algorithms so actually like everything
you find it in a standard machine
learning textbook will be implemented
there like classification regression
k-means clustering DB scan whatever
tease me and there's all of these
algorithms together with tools to
evaluate these algorithms and tools to
tune hyper parameter to cross-validation
and these things it's been pretty
successful like here's some logos of
companies that worked with it but
actually I think most companies now that
do machine learning somewhere use it in
some place so it's a heavily used
industry and also like a bunch of
research so we nearly have ten thousands
research since thousands as attachments
on the paper which would really makes me
want to be on the paper which I'm not so
so ii learned is a really big community
effort so this are like these are the
core developers I think there's about 40
there's about 50 people contributing
every month so I'm not the person who
created it that are some people in the
top row but I've been like one of the
core developers for the last seven years
or something like that so what we're
really proud of in second learn is in
particular our documentation which I you
should definitely check out some people
said oh you don't need to read a machine
learning books you can just read the
documentation I don't entirely agree
with this but I think we did a pretty
good job in particular we have like a
a bunch of examples so you can go
through and look at the gallery and see
how everything works and I think that's
pretty good right so I want to talk to
you about how this actually works and
how you can use it in practice so first
basic API so scikit-learn works on numpy
array so numpy arrays are homogeneous
arrays so that means they have one data
type so they're quite different from
data frames and so we assume that our
input data is some float matrix X where
like each row corresponds to one sample
and each column corresponds to one
feature or want any pendant variable and
so this would be our input and we have a
separate array if we do classification
or regression that is a would be outputs
or labels so we have two different
objects one for data and one for a
targets and so we most of the algorithms
in scikit-learn
assume that everything is a float so by
default none of these work with
categorical data or missing values this
is something you have to take care of
yourself I'm going to talk a little more
about this later but this is sort of the
basic paradigm and we always call with
data acts and the labels why alright so
here's how I think about machine
learning pipeline particular supervised
machine learning which is sort of the
most common used form so you start with
this training data and your training
labels and you built a model which could
be like linear regression and random
force gradient boosting whatever and you
have some new data for what you don't
have labels usually for which you can
want to make predictions often you want
to evaluate how good your model is so
actually you have hold our test data
with test labels which allows you to say
okay my model generalizes just as well
so for me machine learning means that
I'm mostly interested in how well my
model generalizes I'm like and I'll hear
people that maybe have more statistics
background where you're more interested
in understanding the Model Cycle learn
is really tuned towards making
predictions and making accurate
predictions so I don't think there's
none of the values have and none of the
models have any P values associated with
them and scikit-learn so if you're
looking for that this is not the right
thing if you want to make accurate
predictions then scikit-learn will be
helpful all right so this is sort of the
standard workflow and it's we revised
machine learning and this is there's
basically two phases you're trying to
model but is your train data and then
you want to generalize to new data and
this is mirrored very directly in a
second learn API so all the algorithms
since I could learn are implemented as
Python classes so let's say I want to
write enforce classifier there's a
Python class that's called random force
classifier to Train random forests for
classification these objects contain
both the algorithms or encapsulate the
algorithms for building the models and
for making predictions they will also
store all the model parameters so here
for example in the random force
classifier if I call fit fit we'll build
the model and this will store all the
trees all the splits of the trees and so
on in this CLF object all models in
scikit-learn have a fit function and it
always looks exactly the same way it
always gets the training daytime which I
call X train and if it's a supervised
algorithm like here it gets also the
desired outputs y train so this filter
function stores the model and CL in CLF
so this is sort of all you have to do to
build a random forest if you want to
apply this to new data they are CLF not
predict which you input only any new
data at you have or we could also do the
training data and we'll return the
predictions according to the model
there's also a score function which is
basically just a helper function that
does both the prediction and then Avella
weights again against some known ground
truth so see LF that score makes
predictions on X test according to the
model and then you compare to Y test and
then it reports accuracy so this is sort
of the most common interface force I
could learn and like all the models for
classification regression will follow
exactly as interface and you mostly need
to think about fit and predict these are
sort of the core methods
there's another interface since I could
learned it's also very important in
particular in unsupervised learning and
in pre-processing so this is for
unsupervised learning and/or
pre-processing where someone gives you a
training data set and say you want to do
PCA so you have your training data
there's no labels or grand truce or
something like this you just have your
matrix X and you build a model from this
then when you get some new data or you
have your test data you want to apply
this model and this model will give you
a new view of your data so let's say a
projection onto the principal components
or something like that
this is sort of a slightly different
task and has a slightly different
interface so the way this works since I
could learn is again everything is
encapsulated I was an object so if I
have PCA hey I want to do PCA I
instantiate the PCA object I call fit
again all things in scikit-learn have a
fit method and so here I just give it
the training data X because it's an
unsupervised method and then if I want
to actually project
to the principal components I used to
transfer method on any data this will
give me my new view my new
representation of the data X new so
these are basically the three main
functions you need to understand for
scikit-learn is so we call our models
estimator so estimators could be
anything like random forests or scaling
your data or something like this I'll
have a fit method they always take the
data X if it's a supervised method it
also takes some target output Y if you
predict something that is like a
labeling so for classification
regression and clustering you use the
predict method to make this prediction
and if you want to get a new few of the
data a new representation in new acts
you use the transfer method which is
used for pre-processing dimensionality
reduction feature selection and feature
extraction
so these are sort of the two main
building blocks are things to transform
your data and things to make predictions
and we also have more building blocks
for sort of standard Rashidah learning
tasks particular from model evaluation
and selection so there's tools to do
trend has split which is like very
simple I'm not actually going to talk
about this but after instead of doing a
training test split you want to use
cross-validation I think you're all
familiar with cross-validation something
I can skip this where you put your data
say in 5 folds and you hold on one fold
and train on the other ones and this
gives you a more robust estimate of
generalization performance of your model
if you want to do that there's a method
called cross vault score in scikit-learn
and Creswell score
sorry not method a function Cresswell's
tool or gets an object data and labels
and you tell us how much
cross-validation you want to do by
default it does three fold stratified
cross-validation here I say I want to do
five fold stratified cross-validation
and so this will return the scores on
the test set or on the holdout set for
each of the iteration so here I get five
scores for the five splits of the data
and then I can compute the mean and
standard deviation or something like
that so this is some like one of the
very commonly used tools another tool
that's probably used even more commonly
is to do a grid search to adjust
parameters because all models have
parameters and you always need to tune
them it's always a bit of a pain and so
the workflow that I usually encourage
people to use might not be the one that
you use but that one that I favor is you
take your data you do a training and a
test split then you do cross-validation
or training data set to tune parameters
and then you do a final evaluation on
your test data this way you have an
unbiased estimate of the generalization
performance by running your tuned model
on a test set if you just did
cross-validation to tune your parameters
then
the estimate of generalization
performance that you would have is too
optimistic
so in this workflow which is a things
are the standard supervised learning
workflow for me it's pretty easy to
implement what's I could learn there the
main class here that you need is a great
search civies a grid search TV
implements grid search was cross
validation so if i want to run this
whole process I first put my training
data or my data into a training test
with the Train test put method then I
need to define the parameters I want to
search over so here SVC is a support
vector machine but he faulted use the
RBF kernel there's two parameters
associated with this regularization
parameter C and kernel bandwidth gamma
and so now I specify a grid what values
of C and gamma do I wanna try out and so
here I basically give an exponential
range from like 10 to the minus 3 till
10 2 to 2 and for both seen gamma so
this defines my search space that I want
to adjust the parameters over then to
actually do the search I instantiate an
object a new object with this grid
search CV and it gets the model I want
to tune and the parameter grid I can
also specify which metric to use like I
don't want to use a UC or accuracy or
average precision whatever you want and
how I want to do cross-validation the
cool thing here is that this grid search
TV object returns this grid object in
this grid object just behaves like all
the other models so this thing that does
a grid search for us so has like fit
predict score was exactly the same
interface as everything else only if you
call fit now what it will do is it will
run cross-validation find the best
parameter models according to the
cross-validation score according to
metric I give it and then use this best
model and retrain this model on the
whole training set so after it does grid
search it retrains the model with the
best parameters and so this allows me
then to make predictions so here you see
again this is very
geared towards making predictions it's
very easy to search parameters and then
make predictions with this model on new
data so this is sort of pretty
convenient I think so
one thing I mentioned is that cycle
learn doesn't really automatically do
any pre-processing and so one of the
reasons to do this is because you won't
really have control over what is
happening like how do you want to encode
your variables how do you want to
compute data and so on and so more often
than not instead of taking your training
data on your trading labels and built a
model there's a lot of things happening
in between like extracting features from
text data or images or whatever you have
rescaling your data in the way that you
think makes sense for your data set
possibly doing automated feature
selection and so on and then it's all
goes into your model very common mistake
that people then make is okay then I'm
gonna do cross validation on the model
tune the parameters of the model and
this gives tells me how what my model
will be however if you do this then
you're gonna actually leak a lot of
information in your previous steps for
the cross validation what you really
need to do is make cross validation the
outermost loop and across the very h2
your whole processing pipeline from
feature extraction scaling recheck
selection all the transformation you
want to do and then do cross validation
over list select the best model that the
best parameters and then rebuild your
model to make this very simple second
learn another thing called pipelines so
pipelines are a way to chain together
transformations I call them here t1 and
t2 think about like imputation and PCA
or scaling and PCA or whatever you want
and the classifier and so similar to
cross validation to grits or CV making a
pipeline returns a new object that is
again an estimator has again exactly the
same interface as any of the other
models so this pipe object
looks like a model again only now it's a
chain of the say two transformations and
a classifier so and then if I call a fit
on this model it'll fit the first
transformation transform using the first
for information fit the second card
summation transform using the second
transformation and pass the transform
data on to the classifier if I make
prediction a prediction on new data
it'll do exactly the same
transformations it will not refit the
transformations will just transform the
data and make sure basically the test
date that gets exactly the same
treatment as a train data encapsulating
your whole processing pipeline like this
makes it much more unlikely that you're
leaking information or that you're doing
leaking information from your test set
or that you're doing different steps on
training and test set because you have
encapsulated everything in a coherent
unit you have the cool thing about using
pipelines is well it saves code and also
now you can do cross validation the way
you would want to do it so for example
if I want to scale my data so the SVM in
cycle learn doesn't know scaling I think
by default in Rd Lopez VM wrapper
doesn't like 0 mean unit variance and so
I could learn and sort of it doesn't do
that so you have to do it yourself and
or you could say well it allows me to
choose more precisely how I want to
pre-process my data okay so I can make
this pipeline here this would be scale
the data and then 50 SVM so if I want to
do grid Saoirse with this I can just use
this pipeline inside the great search CV
the only thing I need to adjust is I
need to tell Burt search CV which does
the parameter search which steps inside
the pipeline I need to want to tune the
parameter on and so here and there's
this notation with a double underscore
which basically says under step that's
called SVC tuna parameter C on the step
that's called as we seek to
mature gamma and so this allows you to
do quick search and cross validation
over these complex pipelines and the
cool thing about this is that you can
not only say do scaling and then grid
search the parameters of the model but
you can good search parameters of
everything jointly usually
pre-processing methods like feature
selection also have parameters so for
example here I do feature selection
asking I should use one two three or
four features and so I can select over
how many features should I still should
I select and the parameters seen gamma
off to support vector machine together
in this pipeline so it says here I have
this pipeline select a best is selected
cast k best feature according to P
values the a support vector machine and
now grid search the best value for K and
select K best and the best value for
scene gamma and support vector machine
and so this allows me to search all
these things jointly and they're all
encapsulated in this single grid object
all right I think that's all I had today
so I know that was really fast but I got
twenty minutes and so now you have
almost I could learn nearly yeah I have
this book what you already saw and you
can follow me on Twitter or something
like that
[Applause]
you